even just tells this horrible joke he's
a garbage person they don't even use
they don't even list any of the evidence
or all of the claims you're thinkin I
don't have to do that because I'm a
comedian you wouldn't hold anyone else
to the standard right but you dumb
royally because you just so happened to
take the only joke that we've ever done
where the entire setup was a
word-for-word reciting of her testimony
and all the evidence question of the day
before we go to life advice oh here's my
question
honest opinion here why is it that you
think progressives get so angry whenever
anyone of any notoriety sort of
challenges even this you know what no I
don't like that question now is the
question all right at what point do you
think someone should be cut out of a
conversation because we hear this a lot
like I'm not even going to discuss this
with this person because they're a bad
faith actor we hear that quite a bit and
there is a certain point for me it's is
this person beyond any level of proof
that could possibly convince them change
reminder at least cause them to relent
to to relinquish or think of a point
what do you think at what point does
someone not necessarily deserve a spot
at the table and is that for example the
person at SNL is that Dave Chappelle or
yours truly so here's the context really
quickly before we move on to everything
wrong with these arguments but this is
what I'm specifically responding to at
the Young Turks because my my name was
on their lips where's the joke and
that's what all conservatives do they're
like black people you know what I'm
saying no I don't know what you're
saying hey let's like them that's not a
joke oh I mean it's a Crowder does this
all the time I gay people terrible right
that's not a joke I agree with you at
any point any point ever in the history
of this program wherever people show me
any evidence of my comedy being anywhere
near as lazy as the journalism found
over there at the Young Turks that is my
challenge to you and I will again I'd
love to have a conversation with chanc
because again you called me out you
don't debate every single Twitter egg
but if you call me a little there there
should be some recourse um this is them
in a clip supporting the Young Turks and
a lot of people on the Left supporting
the idea of canceled culture right and
it really irks me because a these are
people who've never stepped foot in the
arena and these are people who yeah they
present these these
disingenuous arguments or maybe they're
just wrong
I don't want to say disingenuous I don't
know their intent as to why cancel
culture isn't that really a pervasive
problem but it's really your fault that
people are outraged let's go to the clip
to hear the explanation look is a comic
your whole thing is read the room right
and that's your job
what is the room find funny if the room
doesn't find it funny yelling at them
doesn't make it funnier and so
Chappelle's last anda was terrible
Oh Oh think first of Sam Kinison it
doesn't make it funnier sometimes make
it funnier and here's something else too
that I think is important they try to
create this sort of illusion of it's
just about consequences reaction it's
not canceled culture because the First
Amendment is only about government so
they try to say this is just
consequences for your action it's the
market speaking right I want a second
it's disingenuous or at least incorrect
because 99% of people like Dave
Chappelle's special it's the critics who
have a problem with a 35% and you see
the same thing with deficit tearing down
the house with AOC that people didn't
like it the critics are the ones who
like it this is not something where the
audience or the market has spoken CNBC
ran a headline Dave Chappelle's Netflix
special is offending critics but viewers
don't care though was the fault of the
viewers we're not it's ours this is what
I think you note they try to say this is
an open this is an open market it's
actually not an open market let's not
act as though this is a voluntary sale
of goods and services because a lot of
the times conservatives say well I don't
want to be boycotted listen if people
boycott you that's one thing that being
said right here we are talking about
places like The Young Turks and their B
team we'll get to in a second where they
are the ones they're not acting like
it's more comfortable to Wall Street
speculators trying to manipulate yeah
the market their more comfortable to the
hedge fund elitist who they claim to
hate because they are so out of touch
with the American viewer they want to
have control so let's let's look at that
for a second they run what 98% of media
ABC NBC CBS CNN Google Twitter Facebook
yeah that's it that's pretty much how
would you say if I'm not exaggerating 90
95 % god of information being delivered
here across the United States and they
want to use their bully pulpit to force
everyone to think the same way they do
case in point Dave Chappelle listen
nobody was ever nobody was canceling
their Netflix subscriptions for Dave
Chappelle Dave Chappelle was not harmed
one iota
this channel never negatively what night
couldn't care less if their ads were
running randomly through Google Adsense
or it changed my mind
it's people like The Young Turks it's
people like the Kathy Griffin's of the
world it's people who are the social
justice left who want to get us banned
and removed because the market has
spoken and people enjoy this content
that's what I think they're the ones
pushing on funny material the market
isn't one Hanna Gatsby another example
was a hundred percent we have a hundred
percent do we have 25 percent from no
but this chick does and that's the whole
thing that they said is the Dave
Chappelle got up there and they said
this is not funny getting up there is
holes were empty the market instead here
did impact to record numbers right The
Young Turks who don't who want to stop
you they want to be like the crossing
guard what is it what do they call us
the the hall monitors like no no right
right no one cares yeah and it was
nothing that he said was really
offensive right he was making jokes
about this but they said he got up there
and put the victim card he said the woe
is me act and I'm like did you see the
unfunny special that that lady did in
Australia where she said woe is me the
entire time I want to get to it my sort
of a call out of the internet a call
really a return call don't start at a
young teen that returned young call to
the Young Turks here a return I call a
return call to the Young Turks depta
that's incredibly uncomfortable it's far
more racist than a jokes that we've ever
made its market forces that's important
in something else this is the Young
Turks B team here they are trying to
coach you on what comedians professional
comedians should do or really
entertainers or anyone like Shane Gillis
who've gone out there and actually put
their necks in the line how you should
deal with canceled culture to appease
them I don't mind them people aren't
willing to accept that but if he said
yeah back in 1987 when I said those
horrible things about gay folks I
totally missed the ball and I apologized
and I've learned from it and I've done
this this this and that to undo what I
did we've talked about something earlier
you go through levels of things to do
things the wrong way go through that
same model ever to do things the right
way
you've gone
this and that in certain level of things
do other such things and items of that
nature what do you say I don't know you
know that as long as you follow this
step-by-step guide will allow you to
continue to make yeah here's one thing
let me tell you guys this don't ever
apologize to the leftist mob okay now
all I apologize if you believe you've
done something wrong let me tell you
this I genuinely believe that if we
apologize we have P we tried to appease
the Vox the the vulture might calm that
gizmo does whatever it was NBC universe
like it's hard to keep trying on others
alone which we would be gone we would be
gone here's something important to know
if you don't think you're wrong if it's
not something you want to correct
something that maybe you said that isn't
reflection of what you believe of course
you apologize you correct it but
apologizing just because someone says if
you do that and these other things will
forgive you the left doesn't believe in
forgiveness today let me explain to you
why it stems from Marxism both economic
and cultural and I know there are a lot
of atheist libertarians out there but
stay with me for a second it is a
distinctly Atheist worldview current
progressivism and forgiveness is not a
virtue Oh forgiveness mercy is really
only seen as a virtue in modern
Christian and this is something a lot of
people don't Lisa what about the flaw I
don't need a Flying Spaghetti Monster to
tell me that I shouldn't shoot anybody
well what a second not all societies
were against murder though most were
sought as back even fewer societies but
more saw theft as wrong but not all of
them
that being said mercy forgiveness up
until really modern Christendom were not
seen as virtues strength power respect
instilling fear were seen as more
valuable than forgiveness or mercy this
is important this is why you don't
apologize to people who do not believe
in forgiveness let's compare it to the
right Bill burr I remember his last
special yeah he made fun of Christians
quite a bit remember you said I was a
little rough I didn't necessarily make
it all the way through James okay Dave
Chappelle railed against Trump Dave
Chappelle I think I'm not mistaken
appeared at a rally maybe or alluding to
pushing some kind of gun control the
right didn't say they should never work
again the right is now seeing their new
specials bill bird Dave Chappelle
they've completely forgiven them for any
transgressions like telling offensive
jokes because we know that you can just
turn it off they move on the left
doesn't move on and there are a few
reasons as to why this is the reason
they want people removed entirely from
these platform
from their culture before I actually
finished this notifications please hit
the notification bell if you're
subscribe subscriptions don't mean a
whole lot mug club ladders credit.com
slash mug club join up you get full
access to the daily show and really just
bookmark this page every single day the
content you're not going to find us in a
certain season obstruct the reason they
do this the reason they want people
removed from platforms is so that they
so that they can present the narrative
including the arguments of their
opponents in the way they want you to
perceive it as you see here where's the
joke and that's what all conservatives
do they're like people you know what I'm
saying no no I don't know what you're
saying
Latinos who likes them that's not a joke
that is not a joke right that's not a
joke okay again challenge when have we
ever done this chanc Anna please send me
any example of me saying gays might let
me go through the kind of these jokes
from last year this is what they try to
do they try to separate the affront what
hurt their feelings from the actual joke
so last week alone Thursday alone we did
a smells like teen spirit shot-for-shot
parody a joke about Hannah gasps me
winning the Emmys Elon omar banging her
brother Joe Biden quadrupling us
population with his gaffe Andrew yang
being attacked by box we did a bit about
priest bombing cities with holy water
the Canadian Cancer Society feeding
transgender men on their page regarding
cervical cancer quarterblack Garrett did
a bit with India's farting contest and
we had women getting surgery to combat
resting face you may not like any of
those other jokes but that is not what
we did and by this is so this is why
they want people like us removed because
they can say all these things gay thug
but we don't check you there now who
said that this is also by the way while
we show these clips please go watch the
entire video I know it's tough I know
it's Anna or do I want to watch the
b-team reiterate what Jake and Anna have
said sometimes it's just like a palate
cleanser it's like lime sorbet only it's
poisonous lime sorbet yeah
okay look even if we do a dislike do
some jokes on one of these groups right
we do it on every group equally and
we're not saying that we dislike equal
people I don't think that we've ever
come in here and said we don't like gay
people
we don't like transgender people we
don't like putting forward ideologies
that aren't good for society and that's
what we're really pushing back against
if they weren't pushing it so hard we
wouldn't have tuned by the way the
reason that they have a problem with
this is that nobody on the left does any
comedy against the left that's why this
is so unique right always on the right
we get hit every single time that's why
bill bursts thing was a little rough for
me it's because I hear it from
everywhere if I didn't hear from
everywhere it would have been funny yeah
you know well but this is the first time
shanks shanks the authority on all
things oh really
this is again the challenge do you find
any example of what it is they're saying
and this is why they want us gone so
they can say what we say good example
they even did this with the Christine
Blasi Ford joke yeah where the joke they
just show the punchline city authorities
are still allowing for the possibility
that Christine Ford is a lying [ __ ]
that's the joke the young turks said and
you know and here's the thing Stephen
just tells this horrible joke he's a
garbage person they don't even use they
don't list any of the evidence or all of
the claims you're I don't have to do
that because I'm a comedian you wouldn't
hold anyone else to this standard right
but you've got royally because you just
so happened to take the only joke that
we've ever done where the entire setup
was a word-for-word reciting of her
testimony and all the evidence we listed
the evidence and then of course the
authorities are still allowing for the
possibility that she could be a lying
[ __ ] that was a joke you don't have to
like the joke right but you expand it 30
seconds in either direction and then
people get the context so this is what
bothers me I understand that not
everyone is obligated to debate everyone
else I get that okay I'm not saying this
is that case but since I've been a
channel with 50,000 subscribers The
Young Turks for some reason yeah my name
won't leave their lips so shank you know
that let's sit down and let's talk about
it we've invited you on several times
before we don't attack you without
offering you any recourse let's talk
about canceled culture let's probably
you can cite some examples of me saying
who looks Latinos goes they suck right
you can bring your B team to do your
research and let's hash it out I am
against canceled culture I don't believe
it is a byproduct of market forces I
believe that you and those in the media
the media entertainment industrial
complex let's coin that then yeah the
Media Entertainment industrial complex
who want to be the gatekeepers of
information want to manipulate the
market to bend to their will so they can
tell you guys how to think I don't agree
with it I think it's wrong let's talk
about it shank seems like you're open
since you let my name leave your mouth
but I won't hold my breath if you like
this video click one of these other
videos playing in a box subscribe hit
the notification bell you may be
wondering why after this outlandish
video this is such a straight end card
that's because we've recently learned
that end cards actually determine the
YouTube algorithm as it relates to
controversy on a sliding scale so we
have yellow and it escalates all the way
to the word